Hello everybody, just before we get started
I wanted to say that this is something entirely
new a regular Today I Found Out video will
follow so do not worry if you're looking for
your TIFO fix that will come later today.
For now this is a new experimental series
of videos we're trying.
It's called This Day in History and if you
couldn't guess from the title, we're looking
at this day in history.
This is June 1st.
So, let's crack on, I'd love to know what
you think.
Let me know in the comments below, also give
it a like if you like it.
You know, it's all a work in progress.
So, let us know how we're doing.
So, today we're looking at the Heimlich Maneuver.
According to various interviews given by Dr
Henry Heimlich during his lifetime (he passed
away in 2016 at age 96), the eponymous maneuver
he championed in the 1970s is responsible
for saving the lives of tens of thousands
of people and a not insignificant number of
dogs...
The genesis of the Heimlich maneuver can be
traced back to 1972 when Dr. Heimlich, who
was a Cincinnati-based thoracic surgeon at
the time before getting fired a couple years
later, read an article in the New York Times
that revealed that over 3,000 people in the
United States died from choking on food in
that year alone.
At the time, the general consensus among medical
professionals was that the best way for a
layman to help a choking person was to slap
them very hard on the back several times.
Heimlich, being an expert on all things chest-related,
reasoned that a better method would be to
more directly leverage the air in the lungs
to force the blockage out.
Basically, if you put pressure on the lungs,
the sealed balloon-like organ would naturally
provide the force necessary to dislodge the
food.
To test his hypothesis he couldn't exactly
go around getting humans to choke, so Heimlich
started by doing this to beagles.
Specifically, Heimlich and his team put small
tubes in the dogs' throats that made it difficult,
though not impossible, to breathe.
Once the dogs were choking, initially he experimented
with pressure to the chest itself to expel
the tube, but found this ineffective.
In further experiments, Heimlich noticed that
if he pressed on the dog’s diaphragm just
right, thus compressing its lungs, the tube
would sometimes even violently be dislodged.
In fact, he noted on some test runs that the
tube would fly out of the dogs' mouths and
travel several feet across the room.
You might at this point be wondering if things
ever went wrong in the experiment, resulting
in significant harm or death of a dog; Heimlich
claims none of the dogs suffered any lasting
injury and removal of the tube was a straightforward
process- you just grab the tube and pull it
out if things got dicey.
After perfecting the technique for dislodging
tubes, Heimlich then began a slightly more
dangerous procedure, giving the dogs comically
large chunks of meat to eat- meat the dogs
occasionally choked on, allowing him to perform
the technique under more realistic conditions.
(Again, he claims no dogs were permanently
hurt as a result of these experiments.)
After adapting the technique for humans, Heimlich
felt this method needed to be widely disseminated
to save lives immediately, rather than going
through the normal medical research progression
including publishing a peer-reviewed study.
After all, it might have taken years to prove
the efficacy of the technique over existing
recommendations and then very likely many
years more before any official medical body
would recommend it to the public, if it all.
And so it was that on this day in history,
June 1, 1974, Heimlich published an article
titled, Pop Goes the Café Coronary, in Emergency
Medicine.
(For reference here, Café Coronary is just
a bit of a slang way to say cardiac arrest
as a result of choking on food.)
Heimlich also pulled some strings to have
a friend who wrote for the Chicago Daily News
get the article published there, with the
friend explicitly noting, "Dr. Heimlich doesn't
know that his method will save a choking person..."
but then going on to recommend trying anyway.
As to the original article, Heimlich does
note, "It's been tested only on dogs but I
believe the logic of the concept and the favorable
findings warrant public dissemination..."
He goes on:
Since aspiration must occur during inspiration
in order for the bolus to be sucked against
the laryngeal orifice, the victim's lungs
are expanded at the time of the accident - actually
there is always residual air in the lung - so
sudden forceful compression of the lungs will
increase the air pressure within the trachea
and larynx and thus eject the offending bolus
like the cork from a champagne bottle.
There, in short, are the dynamics of the procedure.
And here's how to do it:
Standing behind the victim, the rescuer puts
both arms around him just above the belt line,
allowing head, arms, and upper torso to hang
forward.
Then, grasping his own right wrist with his
left hand, the rescuer rapidly and strongly
presses into the victim's abdomen, forcing
the diaphragm upward, compressing the lungs,
and expelling the obstructing bolus.
The same effect can be obtained with the victim
lying face down on the floor, the rescuer
sitting astride the victim's lower torso or
buttocks.
If, however, the victim is already lying on
his back, he needn't be moved.
The rescuer merely sits astride him and suddenly
presses both hands - one on top of the other
- forcefully into the upper subdiaphragmatic
abdominal region...
We cannot be certain, of course, that the
experimental results will be duplicated in
humans.
But when tracheostomy is not feasible, there
is certainly no risk in recommending that
the procedure be tried in actual cafe coronary
emergencies since an unaided victim will die
in minutes.
Then, as experiences are reported, the method
can be evaluated.
Only by disseminating public information about
this simple technique can we determine whether
it will result in a significant reduction
of what amounts to 3900 totally avoidable
deaths every year.
This article, or snippets of it, quickly got
re-published in hundreds of newspapers throughout
the United States.
Within weeks, reports began pouring in from
people across the United States about how
the technique was saving lives.
Later that year, the Journal of the American
Medical Association called Heimlich and told
him they were going to name the technique
after him.
After vetoing the name The Heimlich Method,
Heimlich settled on The Heimlich Maneuver,
which he felt was “more appropriate”.
Naturally, given a lack of hard evidence supporting
his method in favor of existing recommendations,
institutions such as the American Red Cross
chose not to initially recommend the Heimlich
maneuver, which in turn caused Heimlich to
decide to market it himself, including selling
shirts and posters, and even going on The
Tonight Show to demonstrate it on Golden Globe
award winner Angie Dickinson.
At this point you might be wondering if this
method actually is superior to the former
widespread recommendation of just hard back
slaps.
It turns out this is remarkably difficult
to say, though perhaps that shouldn't be unexpected
given to study the matter in a scientifically
rigorous fashion on humans isn't really ethically
possible.
As for statistics, when Heimlich first got
his bright idea a little over 3,000 people
per year died from choking in the United States.
In the two decades following the widespread
use of the Heimlich, the number of choking
deaths in the U.S. stayed approximately the
same as it was before…
Later, in 2000, there was a rather curious
sudden jump from 1995's 3,185 to 2000's 4,313
deaths.
The number stayed mostly stable until 2010
when it further jumped to 4,570, with it rising
a bit since, with the high mark here on choking
deaths in the United States occurring in 2015
at 5,051 people.
Given the lack of hard evidence supporting
the Heimlich over back slaps, starting in
2006, the American Red Cross, besides still
recommending first encouraging the person
to cough if they can and having someone call
911, they actually switched to recommending
back slaps before trying the Heimlich and
then alternating between the two at five times
each.
As for the reason for adding the back slaps
back in, according to American Red Cross representative
Mike Higgins, Red Cross officials determined
that, to quote, "the body of scientific evidence
now states that the use of more than one method
[is] most effective in helping a person who
has an obstructed airway..."
Of note here is that the American Red Cross
(while being a very reputable organization)
is not part of ILCOR (The International Liaison
Committee on Resuscitation)- basically, the
group most all trained emergency medical providers
throughout the world use when recommending
guidelines for treating people in emergency
situations.
On that note, the American Heart Association
is part of ILCOR and recommends in choking
situations that both medical professionals
and laymen perform the Heimlich on a conscious
person and chest compressions (the same ones
as in CPR) on an unconscious person.
If this is unsuccessful at dislodging the
blocking object, medical professionals are
then trained to perform a cricothyrotomy (cutting
a hole in the neck), which, of course, is
not something untrained individuals should
try.
Should you be the one choking and you’re
by yourself, researchers at the Royal Brompton
Hospital found that self-administered abdominal
thrusts produced just as much intrathoracic
pressure as when someone else does it.
And for maximum effect, they found doing the
abdominal thrusts via forcibly collapsing
your abdomen on the back of a chair produced
the highest intrathoracic pressure of all.
Going back to back slaps and the Red Cross'
recommendations, Heimlich stated, "I have
no desire to diminish the good work that the
American Red Cross has done, such as in times
of natural disasters, but telling people to
hit a choking person on the back could potentially
lead to death.
The Red Cross should do what the American
Heart Association does—recommend the Heimlich
Maneuver…”
He then elaborated, "It’s been scientifically
proven that hitting a choking person on the
back can drive an object that is partially
blocking the airway more deeply into the throat."
It is not entirely clear as to what studies
he's referring to that supposedly scientifically
proved this is the case.
That said, at least when talking comparing
the two with regard to internal pressure,
a 1982 Yale study, Choking: The Heimlich Abdominal
Thrust vs Back Blows: An Approach to Measurement
of Inertial and Aerodynamic Forces, determined
the Heimlich produces significantly more intrathoracic
pressure than back slaps.
It is noted, however, that this study was
partially funded by the Dysphagia Foundation
Inc. of Cincinnati Inc., later renamed the
Heimlich Institute.
That said, just because Heimlich helped fund
the study, doesn't necessarily mean the results
were inaccurate, and the three Yale researchers
involved, Richard L. Day, Edmund S. Crelin
and Arthur B. DuBois, would later state that
their research was completely independently
performed with no oversight or pressure from
Heimlich.
DuBois further stated the experiment was rather
straightforward and easily verifiable by others,
simply measuring air pressure out of the mouths
of subjects when the researchers performed
back blows and abdominal thrusts.
In response, representatives from the Red
Cross noted that the point of the back blow
is more for the jarring effect to dislodge
the stuck object, rather than creating an
artificial cough using air pressure to dislodge
it as in abdominal thrusts- hence their recommendation
to do both methods.
As for one Dr. Roger White of the Mayo Clinic
and American Heart Association, he states
of his opinion of Heimlich and his work, "There
was never any science here.
Heimlich overpowered science all along the
way with his slick tactics and intimidation,
and everyone, including us at the AHA, caved
in."
Heimlich's son, Peter Heimlich also had less
than glowing reviews of his father's assertions,
stating, his father was "a spectacular con
man and serial liar..."
Peter has since dedicated years of his life
to debunking many of the things Dr. Heimlich
would say publicly.
That said, it is almost universally thought
among medical professionals that the Heimlich
maneuver is a fantastic tool to help choking
victims until medical professionals arrive.
And, as noted, even those medical professionals
will usually start by attempting the Heimlich
or chest compressions before moving on to
other methods at their disposal for saving
a choking person.
But while the Heimlich Maneuver itself has
been a boon to the world of choking victims,
earning Heimlich more than a little positive
fame, Heimlich's later career was marked with
controversy owing to doing things like publicly
championing the Heimlich maneuver to help
people suffering from asthma attacks, heart
attacks, and cystic fibrosis, as well as advocating
its use with drowning victims.
The last one there caught on somewhat, owing
to seeming to make sense on the surface- trying
to force the water out of the lungs.
However, the American Red Cross Advisory Council
notes, “Studies have shown that there is
no need to clear the airway of aspirated water.
Only a modest amount of water is aspirated
by the majority of drowning victims and it
is rapidly absorbed into the central circulation.
Therefore, it does not act as an obstruction
in the trachea...
An attempt to remove water from the breathing
passages by any means other than suction...
are unnecessary and potentially dangerous.”
With the danger here noted as potentially
causing physical injury, vomiting and potential
subsequent aspiration, and the fact that doing
this delays the gold standard recommendation
to the public here in cases of an unconscious
drowning victim who isn't breathing- CPR until
professional medical aid arrives or the person
is revived.
(Although, to be fair here, proper administration
of CPR is guaranteed to also cause physical
injury via breaking the cartilage that attaches
the ribs to the sternum in an attempt to compress
the heart, but in this case actually for a
proven effective purpose.)
As with its use in aiding choking victims,
it doesn't appear as if Heimlich took the
time to do the necessary research to definitively
show the Heimlich maneuver is actually more
helpful than standard recommendations in these
cases before widely publicizing it as such
in the media.
This was succinctly pointed out by cardiologist
Dr. Joseph Ornato, who stated of the controversy,
"Dr. Heimlich is trying to force the medical
community to adopt a measure that is lacking
in adequate scientific foundation.
But if studies show he is right, I'd be the
first one to want to apply it."
Later, much more controversially, Heimlich,
in conjunction with the Heimlich Institute
and doctors from China and Ethiopia, were
intentionally infecting people that had AIDS
with malaria and then not treating them for
the malaria until the disease had progressed
to a critical state...
Known as malariotherapy, the idea here was
to try to cure the person of HIV by raising
the body temperature to extreme levels via
a malaria induced fever for an extended period.
These extreme high fevers potentially would
be allowed to be maintained even for weeks
without treatment, with the hope that the
HIV would not survive such a scenario.
Not without precedent, in 1927 this was a
Nobel Prize winning treatment for syphilis,
but in this case the experiments the Heimlich
Institute were involved with were considered
too dangerous, unethically administered, and
with little hope that it would actually do
anything beneficial.
Heimlich's response: "If all of your peers
understand what you've done, you haven't been
creative."